L
SECURITY.
WE'LL EXPLAIN.
BUT WE BEGIN WITH INSULTS AND
ACCUSATIONS FLYING TONIGHT
BETWEEN A GROUP OF HOUSE
DEMOCRATS AND FELLOW DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR.
INVOLVES OMAR'S STATEMENTS U.S.
AND ISRAEL LIKENING THEM TO
TERROR GROUPS HAMAS AND THE
TALIBAN.
WE GET BLOW BY BLOW TONIGHT FROM
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE.
GOOD EVENING, KEVIN.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THE CONTROVERSY ACTUALLY BEGAN
WITH CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR POSTED A
TWEET APPEARING TO SUMMARIZE
VIRTUAL EXCHANGE WITH SECRETARY
OF STATE ANTONY BLINKEN AND WHAT
SOME CONSIDERED FAIRLY
INCENDIARY LANGUAGE.
WE HAVE SEEN UNTHINKABLE
ATROCITIES COMMITTED BY THE
U.S., HAMAS, ISRAEL, AFGHANISTAN
AND THE TALIBAN.
CRITICS BLASTED WHAT APPEARED TO
BE LANGUAGE EQUATING THE U.S.
AND ISRAEL WITH THE HAMAS GROUP
AND WITH THE TALIBAN.
IN FACT CRITICS INCLUDING
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF HER OWN PARTY
DEMANDED THAT OMAR CLARIFY HER
COMMENTS WRITING IN PART IN A
STATEMENT, THE UNITED STATES AND
ISRAEL ARE IMPERFECT.
THEY WENT ON TO SAY THIS:  AND
LEAK ALL DEMOCRACIES AT TIMES
DESERVING OF CRITIQUE BUT FALSE
EQUIVALENCIES GIVE COVER TO
TERRORIST GROUPS.
OMAR ACCUSING HER COLLEAGUES OF
PERPETUATING ISLAM IF I CAN
PHOBIC TROPES CALLS THE LETTER
OFFENSIVE AND A SIGN OF
HARASSMENT AND SILENCING THAT HE
SHE FINDS UNBEARABLE.
IN HER CLARIFICATION, BRET, SHE
SAYS I WAS IN NO WAY ESQUATTING
TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS WITH
DEMOCRATIC COUNTRIES WITH WELL
ESTABLISHED JUDICIAL SYSTEMS.
MEANWHILE, FELLOW MEMBERS OF THE
SQUAD LEFT LEAPT TO OMAR'S
DEFENSE INCLUDING AOC,
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
INCLUDING THOSE IN HER PARTY
INTENTIONALLY DISTORTING HER
REMARKS.
SICK AND TIRED OF THE MISS
CHARACTERIZATION AND PUBLIC
TARGETING OF ILHAN OMAR COMING
FROM OUR CAUCUS.
SHE ADDED THIS:  THEY HAVE NO
CONCEPT FROM THE DANGER THEY PUT
HER IN BY SKIPPING PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS AND LEAPING TO
FUELING TARGET NEWS CYCLES
AROUND HER.
RASHIDA TLAIB FREEDOM OF SPEECH
DOESN'T EXIST FOR MUSLIM WOMEN
OF THE CONGRESS.
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT DOESN'T
EXIST FOR MUSLIM WOMEN IN
CONGRESS.
HOUSE LEADERSHIP SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF TONE.
POLICING OF CONGRESSWOMEN OF
COLOR.
TRYING TO QUELL THE UPROAR THEY
SAID THEY, QUOTE, WELCOMED THE
CLARIFICATION FROM THE